good
thank you
thank you
thank you
right
this
foreign
we're going to be ready in about five
minutes
so
um
uh
so
the speakers are now heading down will
be about a couple minutes from now
so
so
we are waiting for president biden to
finish remarks
on live tv and then they'll come down
you
you
okay
check one two three four
um
um
uh
um
okay
the president is done speaking they're
on the way in shortly
now
yes
okay
[Music]
right
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
mr mayor you want to come on this side
just a minute
council president
i'll go
can you see
everybody's up
good afternoon i am attorney ben crump
along with attorney chris stewart
attorney tony romanucci
attorney justin miller attorney scott
madison
matt matheson attorney
michelle gadot
attorney jeff storms
attorney bavani
and i'm just attorney madeline simmons
and a great team of lawyers
on our team we are honored to stand here
with the family of george floyd his
brothers
and sisters his children all his family
his daughter
gianna we are very grateful to stand
here
at this historic moment in the city of
minneapolis
we are very thankful to the leadership
of the city of minneapolis and i will
talk about that momentarily
but we want to start
from the beginning
when george floyd
was horrifically killed
on may 25th 2020
it was a watershed moment for america
it was one of the most egregious
and shocking documentations
of an american citizen being
tortured to death by a police officer
for having his knee on his neck for
eight minutes
and 46 seconds
one of the worst ever witnessed in
history
in history we're judges
for how we responded to this tragedy
history will judge us on
our commitment to the principles of
equality
in response to this tragedy history
would judge us
on our commitment to the principles
of justice how we responded to this
tragedy
and most of all history
will judge us on our commitment
to our principles of humanity
of how we responded to this tragedy
and mayor frye history
won't judge us just based on the
eloquence of our words
but by the power of our actions
council president bender when this
tragedy happened
and after the family had an independent
autopsy and we were
waiting to have the homegoing services
for george floyd
president joseph biden
[Music]
and former louisiana congressman
cedric richmond you remember chris
came to meet with the family of george
floyd
and his family his sisters and brothers
his daughter gianna was there
and the one thing i remember for loners
about that
was sharing with president biden
what me and my eight-year-old daughter
brooklyn often talk about
and i tell her in life
it's not just enough to say you care
but you must show you care by your
actions
and i remember talking
with rodney and folonis
and all of them by our side in that very
emotional meeting as president biden
shared his empathy for the family and
losing a loved one
i remember talking to him about
when i talked to my daughter brooklyn
about
it's not just enough for america to
say that george floyd life matters
we have to show that george floyd life
matters by our actions
it's not just enough for america to say
that black lives matter we have to
show that black lives matter
by our actions so
the family of george floyd and our legal
team
are very grateful to mayor
frye and the city council
for not just saying you care about
george floyd
but showing that you care about george
floyd
not just saying that black lives matter
but showing to the world that black
lives matter
and we are very grateful and we applaud
you
for this great step of showing the world
responsible
leadership
the leaders of the city of minneapolis
have demonstrated
by their actions and their commitment to
equality justice and humanity
today they have shown that the life of
george floyd
and black lives matter to them
to the people of minneapolis and on
behalf of
george floyd's family we applaud
this responsible city leadership
and we urge everybody
to practice responsible leadership
in remaining calm
engaging in peaceful protests for george
floyd
and reflecting the same humanity
of the man that we are remembering and
honoring today
in george perry floyd because brandon i
think it
may have been on one of the social media
posts and i know you and he talked
regularly on social media and text
george floyd himself
during the ferguson unrest
after michael brown
was killed by the police there and
everybody was saying hands up
don't shoot george floyd shared on
social media
that everybody needs to remain peaceful
as we stand up for justice for michael
brown
so we urge everybody in minneapolis
everybody at 38th and chicago everybody
around the world let's follow george
floyd's example
and being peaceful as we stand up for
justice
can we all do that can we all do that
for george floyd
can we all do that for our children
it is my great honor to announce that
george floyd's family our legal team
and the city of minneapolis and its
leaders
have settled the civil lawsuit in the
death of george floyd
the settlement is not
just historic because of the 27 million
dollars paid out
but for the impact on social justice
policy reforms and police reforms
because the financial compensation
most directly impact george floyd and
his family
the future of their family but it is the
policy reforms that affects
all of us and many would say
that's why the george florida act
whether it's here in minneapolis memphis
or the george floyd justice and policing
act
councilman ellison that is being
contemplated in washington d.c
it impacts all of us all of us
and that's why this is so historic
and significant
i must get
again really acknowledge mayor jacob fry
council president lisa bender
councilman jeremiah ellison
and my dear friend council vice
president
andrea jenkins for their extraordinary
leadership to bring justice and change
out of this terrible tragedy
for the city's leaders and their lawyers
especially their city attorney jim
router
the flora family and our legal team
to reach this historic settlement it
says to america
that we can do more than just point
fingers accuse one another
and engage in more division
we can actually come together and make
things
better we can reach an agreement about
what form justice might
take not wait for it to be determined
only by a historical
discriminatory criminal justice system
but responsible leadership says we
do what we can to try to determine
how we make a better world for all of
our children
after the eyes of the world rested on
minneapolis
in its darkest hour
now the city can be a beacon
of hope and light and change
for cities across america and across the
globe
this would not have been possible
would not have happened without the
extraordinary
progressive and deeply moral leadership
of this city council and its mayor
and for that we do applaud you publicly
as we have applauded you privately
i i look at bolognas
and brandon and
rodney and i'm thinking of bridgette and
zsa
as well as latonya especially
gianna and their other loved ones
and i think about george floyd
and i pray for them on this journey for
justice as i
implore you all to pray for them
i mean it's going to be a long journey a
long journey
to justice this is but one step
on the journey to justice
we have to remember in the 10 months
since we learned
his name we have come to know george
floyd
as a larger than life figure literally
with an even larger personality
and tony ramonucci as we learned with an
even bigger heart
george floyd knew that being a large
imposing black man
made him a target and put him at risk
that's why chris he tried to de-escalate
the situation that day karen he was
assuring the officers
that he was not resisting and that he
did not pose a threat
and justin he was literally doing what
black people do on a daily basis in
america
when they have encounters with law
enforcement
we try to tell them that we're
legitimate people
are three we try to tell them we're not
the type of person that
you're prejudging me to be
we are people human beings just like you
and we just want to be treated like you
treat
others that's what george floyd was
doing
he wasn't posing a threat you look at
that video for yourself
why would they do that to a human being
george floyd had more witnesses to his
torture and death than any
other person black or white
in american history over
50 million people have
clicked to watch that video
and once you see that video you can
never
unsee that video and that's why
george floyd is changing the world
because we know america we're better
than this
we know america that we're more just in
this
we know america that we're more humane
than this in this historic agreement
the largest pre-trial
settlement in a police civil rights
wrongful death case in u.s history
makes a statement that george floyd
deserved better
than what we witnessed on may 25th 2020
that george floyd life matters
and by extension black lives matter
it sends a message that the unjust
taking a black life
will no longer be written off as trivial
unimportant or unworthy
of consequences
and i digress just for a moment
as we acknowledge this historic
milestone
to re recognize that tomorrow
will mark the one-year
passage of time since
our sister briana taylor was killed in
louisville kentucky
and the fact that her and george floyd
will be forever linked in history
as two people who were taken from us
at the hands of the people who were
supposed to protect then
serve them during
the cobit 19 pandemic what seems like
everything else in america has shut down
except implicit bias
and police excessive use of force
and so polonius i know you and
rodney have just spoke with tamika
palmer
text with tamika palmer brianna's mother
and it just demonstrates for all of us
we're inconceivably linked together
as not just black people
not just as americans but as human
beings
and we have empathy for one another she
was celebrating
and congratulating the floyd family even
though
she's dealing with what only one could
imagine
is the worst nightmare any parent could
ever
conceive
and so nothing will ever wipe out the
flora's family
aching loss but this settlement and the
respect that shows the family
will allow healing to begin council war
president bender
it will help to heal the city
of minneapolis and the minds and hearts
of black and white people who
still suffer anxiety and nightmares
and post-traumatic stress from watching
the eight minutes
and 46 seconds of george floyd
torches and killed at the hands of
those who were supposed to protect and
serve them
those 526 seconds
is enough to cause anybody
post-traumatic stress
and we say to everybody black
white brown and red
we're better than this we're better than
those 526 seconds
mere fries we talked about a man
begging for just humanity
just take your knee off his neck
as you were here more than a minute this
city has already enacted some very
profound
model police reforms in the wake of
george floyd's death
our legal team is committed to support
the city and pushing through additional
reforms
mayor frye to ensure
that they can hold officers accountable
for bad conduct
and never let a union contract
force him into having to tolerate
bad policing we have to speak
truth to power george floyd deserves
that
brianna taylor deserves that
mayor fry you have our word
our voices and our might
to help you muscle through additional
changes
that will transform policing in
minneapolis
and hopefully policing in america
councilman ellison
council vice president jenkins council
president bender
and i say this to our national leaders
we hope the example that you all are
sitting here in minneapolis will inspire
and embolden the united states senate
to join their colleagues in the united
states
house of representatives led by the
congressional black caucus
in passing meaningful reform legislation
in the name of george floyd as
congresswoman sheila jackson lee reminds
us
that george floyd justice and policing
act
because like the activists say his name
in the halls of congress with the
passage of that
legislation they will always say
george floyd's name
finally karen i am most proud
with the family and our legal team
of the leadership of mayor frye council
president bender councilman ellison and
vice president jenkins for
engaging in a partnership with the
family that they can take the lead
on being able to contribute
five hundred thousand dollars of this
settlement
to be committed to help lift up
the historically black neighborhood that
engulfs 38th in chicago avenue
where george floyd lived and died while
he was here
in minneapolis be able to uplift
the black businesses that have suffered
vice president jenkins
such a toll in the past 10 months
for the past 10 months
people came to 38th in chicago
to lay down flowers and pay their
respects
i believe people chris will always
come to 38th in chicago
but they will come to remember george
floyd but i pray
that we can make this memorial more than
just that
for loners we want to imagine if in the
future
because of your family's help and
commitment
and giving back to this community
that when people come to 38th
in chicago they will witness a marker
of a turning point in civil rights
they will learn more about black history
they will support the thriving black
businesses
that were able to survive not only covet
but this terrible tragedy where george
floyd was killed
and they will be able to celebrate black
culture
this is our vision united
the family and the city leadership
this is the family's belief
what is proper in preserving the legacy
of george floyd
here in minneapolis
it was his daughter gianna who said
her daddy changed the world
and i know her mother roxy and everybody
know that he certainly has
i thank the leadership of the city of
minneapolis
for elevating and memorializing george
floyd's
legacy today and make us making this
statement
in the clearest terms possible
black lives matter black lives matter
at this time you will get to hear from
[Music]
two of the most passionate
committed skillful
and are uh just
skill beyond anything that you would
imagine
in your local community
but they're not just good because
they care about the court cases
they are skilled because they truly care
about
their clients you from here from my
brother chris stewart
who hails from atlanta georgia and then
you will hear
from my brother tony romanucci
who hails from chicago illinois chris
stewart
it's something that
the two most viral videos
that deal with george floyd are his
death
and life the video of gianna floyd
saying my daddy
will change the world and who would have
known that from the mouth of a babe it
would actually come true
who would have known what that change
would be because it's not just
a large financial number it's deeper
than that
the number today changes evaluations and
civil
rights for a black person when they die
because what you don't know is the
rigged game that we always have to play
when we take one of these cases because
african-americans are not
valued high when they are murdered by
law enforcement
in these cases and we are changing that
precedent
because as we told you when we felt this
lawsuit six seven months ago
we are here to support the actual
understanding that black lives matter
but you will start understanding that
black
value matters and what happens is that
trickles down
to decisions in the communities across
this country
when there's a city council or mayor
deciding oh should we get
rid of no knock warrants should we get
rid of chokeholds do we want to change
these policies
they have 27 million reasons now why
they should
and that will make decisions happen that
will make accountability happen
because yes it's sad seeing a video of a
man being tortured and murdered but it's
worse having to write
a check to take care of something that
should have been
prevented in other cities and that's why
this is a blueprint and this doesn't
happen often
you don't get a city council that cares
i know i
run into a lot that don't you don't get
a mayor that will step
out there and risk himself to try and
get this done with city council
you don't get a city attorney who
actually worked with us
and it wasn't a fight all the time
that should be a blueprint across this
country
i tried to say that in walter scott
years ago here is a blueprint we changed
policies there was a record number
we worked together we held the
demonstrations peacefully and
change happened in that area what will
happen here
and what will happen across this country
because understand that this isn't over
those officers will be held accountable
there is a prosecution team that
actually cares and is fighting
and if you need a reminder just think of
the george floyd case
and that if you don't get policing
correct if you don't make these changes
if you don't fix the policies that are
happening
then you'll be seeing us again because
we are making sure
that black lives and black value
will be understood
it was an honor fighting for this family
fighting for gianna she had schools
could not be here
with her mother there's been no bigger
joy in my life
uh working with ben and fighting for
not just the man george floyd
but the purpose of what george floyd
change will become across this country
increasing policing making it better and
understanding the value
that will be assigned to african
americans in these cases
thank you
good afternoon everyone my name is
antonio romanucci everybody calls me
tony
i'm from chicago illinois i'm one of the
attorneys
of the george floyd family and hope
again to introduce the entire legal team
soon
i do want to thank my esteemed
co-counsel who spoke before me
my brother ben crump chris stewart
i do want to take a special moment to
thank mayor jacob frye
the city council i want to acknowledge
you now
and again later i have some special
remarks and of course the city attorney
jim router
and also the city attorneys uh brian
carter and tracy fussy
for for working together and
i want to i want to bring you back just
for a moment now
to may 24th george
had no idea he had no clue that when he
laid down for rest that night and he
closed his eyes
that the following day would be his last
that he would breathe
he didn't know that the last two words
that he would utter on this earth
mama mama
would not only be his last words
but would actually be the words
of a messenger because
what you see here on this stage today
doesn't happen you don't see
a concert of people who sit across the
table from each other and typically
fight it out in a courtroom
standing here together not so much
proudly announcing
but in partnership announcing a very
historic settlement
and as chris said the amount may be
historic i know ben pointed it out
but really the historic part of it will
be
in the change that george floyd
brought about george doesn't know
what he has accomplished and what he has
done
but his family are going to be his rays
that will continue to shine down upon us
all
and ensure that his name will never be
forgotten
and will be inscripted with permanent
change
not only in this city but in this state
but also our country and it can't happen
without this community that's standing
on this stage
we are so pleased that this settlement
includes
five hundred thousand dollars which will
be funneled
to some of the most needy and important
businesses
of the neighborhood of 38th in chicago
we will see that that money gets spent
in the right businesses the right areas
of that community
this case has been said as a watershed
event for civil rights in america and
around the world
and it does it does i can tell you that
the feeling does
feel that this is a turning point for
police reform and changes
but that's only because only because
there were conscious choices that were
made to do so
because this wasn't just or will be
a check that's written there's a lot
more behind that
and that's what you have to appreciate
that's happened here
are the conscious choices of of the
minnesota city council
and its attorneys and its executive
branch such as mayor frye
to do the right thing
police in minneapolis they need to
commit themselves to substantial
improvements in culture
and practices now this is also a wake-up
call to every police department around
the nation
to make swift change because if you
don't make make swift change
what happens it's it's called needless
and preventable death needless
and preventable preventable serious
injury
it's a call for lawmakers all over the
country
and especially in the united states
senate as ben
pointed out they must pass they must
vote to pass
the george floyd police and reform act
we know that the president will
sign it once it gets to his desk
what a beautiful thing you think of the
memorial
that is born out of tragic death
if we can have permanent federal changes
not only local changes because of those
last two words that were uttered
mama mama
when somebody says they can't breathe
what is it about that statement that
should not be believed
when someone is kneeling on someone's
neck and they say i can't breathe
that knee should be taken off
with this settlement the community of
38th in chicago
the citizens of minneapolis have
felt some of that pressure relieved
their knee there is no knee on their
but there will always be at some level
a knee on the neck of this family and
for what they have to go through
and that's where the money part comes in
to try and bridge that gap
but it won't it won't until they know
that there will not be another one of
these that happen
george did not need warrior policing
that day
what he needed was help
i can tell you now from a factual basis
and this is so important listen to
some of the great things that the city
of minneapolis has
done that are implemented right now
to prevent what we saw in that videotape
already the city has modified its use of
force policies
so that any hands that ever wind up on a
subject from a police officer
must be reported you think of that
any hands on anyone now is considered
force
and the police must know about it
commanders must know about it
minneapolis has tightened its
requirement for body-worn cameras
it's creating new policies on
de-escalation
so important new policies on disengaging
also when required and
you cannot underestimate the importance
of the social services programs that
they've implemented
to help people to make sure that they
don't die
needless deaths
but as we say in the courtroom partial
justice
is no justice the george floyd family
wants whole justice
and so we demand more changes if true
reform is true to happen
it's true to happen what's been done so
far
is tremendous and we all applaud the
city of minneapolis but we want more
and guess what the city of minneapolis
has said yes
they want more too and we're going to
work together
to make sure that that more does happen
we commit to that
what do we want to do
we want to be working to ensure that
this arbitration process
these union contracts that have become
an absolute
python grip on the police departments
i don't want to break unions but you got
to
give the power to where it belongs you
got to give the power of discipline
to those police chiefs that when they
know something bad happens
that they can take that action
and if we can pass that bill which i
understand needs
state passage that legislation think of
how great it would be to name that
for george floyd
we will also be working with the city of
minneapolis on establishing a use of
force panel
to review all instances of use of force
so if hands go on somebody well
somebody's got to review whether or not
that was reasonable whether
it was necessary we also want to
establish
a quality assurance unit to ensure
that the city's new reform measures are
bringing
are being strictly adhered to
one of the other programs which you
cannot underestimate the gravity of it
or the importance of it
is establishing an early intervention
system with analytics
to ensure that if a police officer
doesn't belong in the force because of
his past
because he's showing a pattern of
discipline
or non-discipline that he'd be removed
once you remove the bad police officers
and keep the ones that we want the good
ones
you're going to see much better
practices on the street
if all of these are implemented
minneapolis
would become the model and what a great
thing that would be in the face of an
historic and tragic death
but we're not done because we did talk
about that five hundred thousand dollars
that the family has committed
to 38th in chicago now
what we're going to do minneapolis
and minnesota is listening we are
challenging
the corporations of this state and of
this city
to match those five hundred thousand
dollars
let's go let's show that you really care
five hundred thousand isn't enough it's
a lot of money but let's go
so the challenge is out there and we
await your call
because if if you don't call we will
we should look forward to looking we
should always be looking forward and not
back
never ever and i was here
in those days after george floyd died
never ever should this city
ever have to suffer again like it did
that's a hard no
lastly i don't want there to be any
surprises
but if the state's going to name a bill
after george floyd
would the city consider something after
george floyd 2.
let's memorialize him in the city and
the state if we can
and it will will be remembered in
perpetuity for a man who did not deserve
to die
a man who will never be able to watch
his daughter gianna grow up to be
that woman that she will be the lady
that she is
to fish with his brother philanese
to text with his nephew brandon
to never hang out with his brother
rodney
he will no longer be a spark in those
lives
so as i wrap up my my remarks
i want to go back to those may days
and that day that i remember being on
the phone with the family and mayor frye
and it's you're going to think it's easy
for me to say this right now
but i can tell you i was a listener on
that call that day when mayor frye
was talking to the family then i told
this to mayor fry
today i said i'm happy to meet you for
the first time in person
because i wanted to see the eyes of
sincerity that i heard the voice
on the phone that day he meant what he
said
they've all meant it they've all stood
up
and they're all trying to take back that
moment in time which can't be taken back
and trying to restore justice to a man
who will never breathe again
who will never be able to call to his
mama again
and never be with his family again
so this day is the result of
thousands of hours of work by the legal
team
and if i may again because they deserve
every single bit of credit
please indulge me and listen to the
names i speak of this legal
team for the great work that they've
done
benjamin crump christopher stewart
justin miller
nicolette ward ian fallon
bovani ravindran who is here today
jeffrey storms madeleine simmons
scott masterson michelle gilbo
alexa ellie kyle nelson
god strike me if i forgot anybody
but also the people that were behind the
scenes that were so helpful
marina fontana michelle uben
jennifer mcgovern mcguffin kelly snowden
again i thank the city council its
members the city attorneys
to the floyd family on this deeply
profound day
you have my highest personal respect
forever for what you have endured
the grace you have shown through all of
this
the honor and the privilege that you've
given me to stand before you
with this legal team and the privilege
to have represented you
you will all forever be a part of our
lives
and now we will hear from
the leadership of the city uh we're
beginning with mayor jacob fry
and thank you again for your tremendous
leadership
thank you mr ben crump mr tony ramonucci
mr chris stewart for your partnership in
furtherance of
justice
the last year more than
any period in recent memory has
delivered
countless moments that will define our
trajectory in minneapolis
for decades and generations to come
today is one such moment a centuries
in the making reckoning around racial
justice
struck minneapolis like a thunderbolt
and that strike reverberated across the
entire globe as we all
stood and watched as george floyd was
killed
every minneapolis resident
every american remembers where they were
when they first saw it
when they first were forced to process
the incomprehensible
recognizing our historic shortcomings
and what we need to do to improve going
forward
there are certain events like that in
world history
that seem to suspend time
where the world stopped and those
moments tend to stick with us
and our black community has endured
deep and compounding trauma over
this last year none perhaps more acutely
than george floyd's family standing with
me right now
i cannot begin to thank them enough
rodney
brandon philonous and keita for their
strength
and their courage their resiliency and
their voices
willing to push us to go forward
not just right now but well into the
future
it is their work that is honoring
the the collective legacy and honoring
their brother
their son their father
and amid unprecedented loss
amid unprecedented pain we now have a
once
in a generation opportunity to truly
effectuate change change that has eluded
policymakers
activists advocates community members
for far
too long some of those laws
and policies on our books today yes they
were built and put into place with good
intention
but the passage of time has caused them
to be calcified
it's caused them to be kept in place at
times by
cynical politics and as a result the
carefully
built trust over time has been lost
has been injured lives have been indeed
cut
short our city
is so grateful to the floyd family
for their warm embrace of meaningful and
overdue
arbitration reform and their commitment
to work
towards justice and peace and safety at
38th
and chicago i want to thank jim router
our city attorney tracy fussy
brian carter and our entire city
attorney's office our communications
team
and everyone that has worked so
diligently and tirelessly
towards this point and have worked
tirelessly over the last nine and ten
months
the work they've done is extraordinary
i also have to acknowledge ben tony
uh and chris and the entire legal team
who also put
in massive and painstaking work to make
today possible
i know they are resolute in their
determination to see
justice i know they are resolute in
their dedication to see
long-term and lasting impact not just in
minneapolis
but nationwide they reached out
to dig in and discuss the reforms that
have taken place they did not stop with
a settlement they did not
flinch when we raised big solutions for
big challenges
and we'll be so grateful to count them
as partners in this very important
reform work
that lies ahead and so today's
settlement
reflects our shared commitment to
advancing racial justice
our command our sustained push for
progress
our commitment to minneapolis and
our commitment and compassion to one
another
we need to be unrelenting we need to be
unapologetic in our pursuit of a more
equitable local government and more just
approach to community safety in our city
and
we will be thank you
mr
mr mayor thank you for your eloquent
words but more importantly thank you for
your actions
to you and all the city leadership uh
i would be remiss if i didn't
acknowledge
uh the other family members of george
floyd
his sister bridget was here earlier this
week
had a death in the family
of her uncle in north carolina that she
had to be present
his brother terence his sisters again
latonya
and jaja his older sisters who
uh helped raise him along with their
mother and father and as philonus
and brandon and rodney will tell you
all grew up in a little small home
with not much more than love in a place
called cuny homes
houston texas and so
at this time you were here
for philonous floyd first
the brother of george floyd
thank you all so much why i'm relieved
that the settlement has been taken care
of
i'd like to thank the minnesota
i'd like to thank our legal team for
standing
with us throughout all times especially
being ben has been here with us for so
long
throughout the times that i needed to
speak with him at
night about my brother about different
things
so i think
i thank the state of minnesota for
getting this settlement taken care of
but even though
my brother is not here
he's here with me in my heart
because if i could get him back
i will give all of this back
him i know that he's with us
and he's standing up right now knowing
that
we have the opportunity to be able to
fund
low-income african-american communities
and that's big in our heart as my family
stand here because
we are a product of our environments we
come from low income we come from the
cuny homes
we are big family i'm a miss my brother
the world he has made a movement
and everybody is standing with us in
solidarity
and i want to be able to thank all the
supporters
all the protesters for standing
especially doing a pandemic where you
didn't have to
yes you put your lives on the line
there's nothing i can do to be able to
repay you for that
because you showed who you are and who
you were
at that time so
one thing that the world needs to know
america we need to heal
this nation needs healing
our family needs healing
it been times where i had to go
and see my brother because he had tears
pouring out his eyes
thinking about our brothers so
everybody around this world who have
marched with us on the front line
or on the couch it doesn't matter
your heart was in a good place and i
like to thank everyone for that
thank you all so much may george live in
power
city of minneapolis
thank you uh for loners for those
heartfelt words now you will hear from
rodney
floyd george's uh baby brother
you know we would like to thank
the state of minneapolis the protesters
that's been here
since day one
and love to thank the mara fry
would like to thank the councilmen and
women of minnesota for
passing this judgment but this is a
small
big step in the joys floor legacy
and um thank you all very much for
supporting us
and we're gonna oppose legacy speak in
his name and thank you guys
for everything
thank you rodney and this next young man
is a nephew of george but as
you all have learned by now they are
a traditional black family and it takes
a village
brandon grew up in the household with
george
and george was more like a father
figure to him than an uncle they talk
constantly and it's with a especially
heavy heart
that brandon comes before you today
because
they lost one of their childhood friends
just
a couple of days ago but he still wanted
to be here
to be with his family in minneapolis
brandon williams
thank you man um
first off starting i want to thank the
city of minneapolis his leadership
special thank you to the mayor
all of our attorneys for all of the
fighting and the hard work that you guys
put in
um and also the ben who's always a phone
call away
no matter if it's late at night or early
in the morning
um he's always there and i appreciate it
i know he's a busy man and
he takes the time out to be there so we
appreciate you man
well today the settlement made history
i think that george made history 10
months ago
we all had you know to witness that
excruciating video
and um it's painful and hurtful
but today you know it's a huge step in
the healing process
when i say healing is not just the pain
that our family feels
well hopefully it's a healing
it's healing in the way that policing
is carried on i think that in those kind
of encounters
a lot of times being a black man or a
black woman in america you fear
encounters with police
they're supposed to protect and serve i
feel that
had the officer de-escalated the
situation
we're not here during this press
conference you know george is still
alive
i think i speak for myself and my family
when i say that we give
the settlement back gladly to have
george still here with us
no amount of money can cure this pain
this heartache
no amount of money you know can bring
him back to be here for his children
know to make memories and watch them
grow
[Music]
every time i come here i get a heavy
heart
you know a lot of emotions start to pour
you know
that's all i have thank you
um
council woman accounts for president and
mr mayor
we have stand up if you have a man
standing up i i think it's important
y'all that we just take a moment that
you you
heard this family pour out their heart
and they did so in a real way
because it's even though this is a
moment
to be uh celebrated still
every day they wake up and they think
about george
and the manner he was taking
that's something that we can never
give them the justice they want because
the justice
would be for george to be here
so all we're trying to do is hold people
accountable
and so i'm grateful that the city is
committed to making sure there's
accountability
and trying to prevent another family
from going through what george went
through
i know attorney stewart talked about
you know you think you
have policy where it won't happen again
but we gotta really commit we
really gotta commit america
that this won't happen again not like
this
we cannot um
therefore i just i just had to say a
word after sending motion from these
family members
thank you mr crump and and thank you to
the family for those
incredibly uh powerful words uh
i'd like to thank our our city council
and and have council president bender up
uh thank you council vice president
jenkins and council member ellison as
well and i'll note that in fact the vote
today was
a unanimous one council president
thank you for your leadership thank you
thank you mayor and thank you to the
family in particular for
the power and emotion we're seeing today
i'm lisa bender
i'm the president of the minneapolis
city council and we did today
as the minneapolis city council
unanimously approve
this 27 million dollar settlement in the
civil lawsuit
filed by george perry floyd's family
against the city of minneapolis
on behalf of the entire city council i
want to offer my
deepest condolences to the family of
george floyd
we know that no amount of money can ever
address the intense
pain and trauma caused by his death
for george floyd's family and just so
many
people in our community who are grieving
minneapolis has been fundamentally
changed by this time of racial
reckoning the minneapolis city council
is united
in working together with our community
with george floyd's family
to bring about a more equitable future
for our city you know i just want to say
mr crow my my girls are about the same
age as your daughter
a little bit older than gianna
i wasn't planning to say this today but
hear your motion
we talk about mr floyd all the time in
our house mr george we say
and we talk about what happened and we
talk about our responsibility
to step up in our family
and you know what i just want you to
know how deeply we're with you
we are with you to go to the senate to
fight for change we are with you to
support
our mayor in chief in implementing
reform we are with you to reshape safety
in minneapolis
we are with you to have the deep
conversations
in every single household in this city
that is needed so that those little
girls
have a different future together
so i just want to again thank the family
so much for their leadership and their
generosity
and supporting the community of
minneapolis in supporting and investing
in 38th and chicago
i want to introduce my colleague our
incredible council vice president andrea
jenkins
who represents the eighth ward and as i
do i also just want to acknowledge the
leadership
of council member jeremiah ellison who
was part of our mediation team and whose
leadership
was crucial in this and so much more of
the challenges that are facing our city
council vice president thank you
uh thank you president uh bender and
um
all of um you that are standing on stage
with me today as we uh make this
historic announcement my name is andrea
jenkins i'm the vice president
of the minneapolis city council and um
i i can't start my my comments
without just operating my
my deep condolences to
all the family members that are here on
stage
with us um all the the members
of the floyd family that you mentioned
uh being that aren't able to be here
with us
in this room but are absolutely here
with us in spirit
and um you know
george floyd's life mattered
and we are here today to honor his life
and his legacy
the killing of george floyd in police
custody last memorial day
has forever transformed the city of
minneapolis
a city that is really from pain
and so much loss and as you've heard
from
our speakers today it has transformed
a family forever changed by the
traumatic
and sudden loss of a brother
father a son
i know firsthand about that trauma and
pain
um of losing a loved one while in the
custody of the police my first cousin
that my mother raised as her son
my little brother you know you said
this is a traditional black family i
come from a traditional black family too
and we always take care of our own
right and so just like
was it rodney that was brandon
that was in the household that's how
my little brother was he was he was
a part of our family and his name
you know this was before hashtags
then um he didn't have an abstract
um we tried to get a lawyer
to help us out nobody would take the
case
he had drugs
he swallowed those drugs in police
custody
and he died nobody would take nobody
would take his case
too many families too many black and
brown
mothers and sisters and cousins and
brothers
know the same pain that your family is
doing
yes and it must stop
it has to stop and hopefully this action
today
uh as chris said there will be 27
million reasons
for it to stop
floyd's death sparked a racial reckoning
around this nation
and around the world a reckoning felt
deeply here
in minneapolis at ground zero
two blocks from where i live
i i look out my window i see a big
portrait of george floyd every day
um this intersection has prompted the
city
to reimagine how public safety
how community safety
how all of safety that
is keeps everybody
in our community safe not just some
people in our communities
out of transformational pain must come
transformational change
this is required of minneapolis
and we are committed to lead the way
because black lives matters in this city
not just george floyd's life
but all black life
i want to just really take a moment to
acknowledge the
um enormous generosity
of the family to uh commit
resources to help out the black
businesses
in this in that community around 38th
and chicago
and and on behalf of those community
members
that i represent i say thank you
um thank you so much
as this trial progresses i do want to
call for peace
i want to echo what um attorney van
crump said that
you know george floyd called for peace
when mike brown was killed
i want to ask for calm in our streets
regardless of the outcome of that trial
the city the council the mayor
the department heads
everybody at the city of minneapolis is
committed
to bringing justice
in more ways than just through our
criminal justice system
we know that we cannot control the
actions of the past
but we do what we do have control of
is actions in the future
in the days and weeks ahead we move
together
to begin a healing process
transformational healing
and today is where that healing begins
and i just want to thank the floyd
family
for their courage their commitment their
perseverance
and fortitude for showing us the way
and leading us towards justice
thank you thank you so much thank you
god bless you
you know council president bender said
something i asked
her and followed us and met fry and uh
just to step up for a second if you
would
because you
do want to chris give an example to
those in the united states senate
that we are better than this
and that there are more things that
bring us together
than to separate us so if we could just
join hands for a second
this is about george this is about
george floyd
and the betterment of america
together we are an example not only for
minneapolis
but for the united states of america
and hopefully the united states senate
can come together like the leadership in
the family came together vice president
jenkins
and we can give president biden a bill
that would be respectful of bearing
george floyd's name
in the george floyd justice and policing
act
that this vision go to the united states
senate
to say that we're better than this
america
and so thank you all at this time i i
if uh jim router who is just being
dogmatic and trying to work to
resolution attorney steward attorney
roman nucci
uh we're gonna start the q
a and uh hopefully one of us
uh attorneys can answer your questions
or direct you to the people who can so
jim you want to say anything before we
start the q a no i'm just
uh grateful and honored to be able to be
with everybody here today and
certainly all the work that uh i've got
to experience with uh
with ben crump here it's been just
transformation
transformation uh so we're opening it up
for q
a and jim to you and your entire staff
as tony ramonuchi said
this doesn't happen unless people are
committed to transformational
change from transformation of pain
um how did you all work with the people
who have been
caretaking the area in george floyd
square and coming to your settlement
vice president jacob
how did you work with the people at 38th
and chicago
how have you all worked with the
caregivers of georgia who have released
the list of demands
to um and i would say this
i know the family has said that they're
going to give
back uh and that was
the family's decision that they want to
be part of the solution
and i think that's what the city
leadership is saying they want to be
a part of solution now we don't have all
the answers
but we believe together we can solve all
the problems
could you talk about the timing of this
settlement now with jury selection going
are you concerned about the trial if you
could talk about the timing of this okay
you know we're trying to be very
respectful
of the criminal proceedings that are now
underway and we're in the middle of jury
selection
and i think it would be very wise for
all of us to
to refrain from commenting on something
that is ongoing i mean i know the
headlines are going to be generated day
in and day out this is a trial where
they're looking for an impartial
i could take that question walks away i
i can take that question
yes sir and i don't know if attorney
stewart or attorney robert
we want to chime in because we do this
type of work all across the country
the one thing we know as black people in
america
that there is no guarantee
that a police officer would be convicted
for killing a black person unjustly
in our country that's what history has
taught us
so we believe responsible leadership
not only like this here but also like
brianna taylor
walter scott and so many others you want
responsible leadership to step
forward and say that we want to help
shape what justice would look like and
not just let it
be a result of a discriminatory racist
criminal justice system
that leaves black bodies lying on the
ground
at the hands of the very people who were
supposed to be trained to protect and
serve them
and there'd be no accountability so i am
grateful
that you have city leadership say no
let's have a better example
than what america has given black people
chris i don't know if you have anything
yeah actually in these situations it can
actually
help the process move uh smoother
without the civil case going i can file
something tomorrow in a civil case
and you all find out all kind of
information that could impact the
picking of this jury the actual criminal
trial
but now that that's over none of that
type of information will be hindering
the criminal trial anyway
um and so far all of us have been
watching like hawks this process
the judge is doing a great job the
lawyers are doing a phenomenal job of
figuring out bias
any views they have um you know
this civil case doesn't have anything to
do with it so to put a fine point
on it why couldn't this wait till after
the trial
concluded well justice really doesn't
really wait
um it happens when it happens and it
happened today um
you know we're not gonna delay justice
because we're worried about
uh the outcome of a criminal trial that
we all pray
you know what what outcome we want i
have a question for mayor frye
i would like to know as being the
significant other
to a man named justin tygan who was
brutally beat to death and thrown in a
dumpster by the
police here in minnesota we have
hundreds of families that led up to
george floyd
and the grievances have gone unmet
i would like to know what have you
and other city officials and other
people in this state done
to address the grievances of the
families
that led up to george floyd
i'll start out by saying i'm so sorry i
i i can hear
the pain in your voice just in that
question alone
there are a number of reforms that have
been instituted i don't think there are
there's any mayor
in the country any city council in the
country that doesn't wish
that they had asked acted faster and
more diligently
the truth is is that we have a history
of shortcomings we need to acknowledge
it
understand that if the impact that it
has had on you
on your family and so many others and we
need to do better
i really appreciate you and your
willingness to stand up and ask
how the city pays for this settlement we
talked about a couple years ago with the
damon settlement 20 million
a once a decade settlement an hour 27
million
i'm curious for property taxpayers how
do we fund
uh this settlement given the
self-insured nature of the city please
thank you for the question i'm going to
bring up our city coordinator mark ruff
who can help answer
good afternoon i'm mark ruff the city
coordinator for the city of minneapolis
um you are correct in the question
around
the city's self-insurance fund so the
city does not have outside insurance
for tort liability for these types of
cases
the city's self-insurance fund is under
pressure not just from
the tort liabilities but also from the
workers compensation associated with
many of our first responders suffering
during this time
so the city has anticipated and started
anticipating with the leadership of our
council on the mayor
some of these liabilities knowing that
we've been living through very difficult
economic times as a country and
certainly as a city
cities downs 40 million dollars in sales
tax we're down 30 million dollars in
parking revenues along with others
but the city has prioritized making sure
that we have enough in reserves so while
our self-insurance fund doesn't have
adequate money right now we do have
other reserves that we have set aside
for these types of liabilities along
with the liabilities of uncertainty is
how quickly we come out of this
recession but at this time
we feel that it is we can confidently
say assuming that
trends continue as they are that this
settlement alone will not result in
property taxes
increasing because of the because of
that judicious nature of
saving the money that's necessary to
follow all of the liabilities that come
out of an event like this
so the question was how that 500 000
is going to be overseen well the family
clearly is going to have is going to
direct how that money is going to be
spent at 38th and chicago we're going to
take direction
from the city council and from its vice
president
who's a member who represents that
district
and and certainly it's going to be
everything every single dollar will be
accounted for
and will be transparent very likely
through a not-for-profit that will be
designated
uh specifically and solely for the the
black brown minority
and impoverished area of 38th in chicago
to help restore
their needs to maybe not entirely as it
was before
may 25th but as close as we can get
and i would simply say it would be the
family's final decision even though
vice president jacobs will uh give us
advice and counsel i think it's
important to know
that whatever is given it will be the
family
that directs where it's going yes sir
could you address there seems to be a
concern in the black community that once
this settlement was announced there was
a collective oh
no will the focus shift from getting
criminal justice before george floyd
with derek shoving and the other
officers involved now that this historic
significant payout is over with will the
focus shift or will you guys continue to
apply
pressure to ensure that there is a
conviction and a proper sentence
with derek shogun whose case is
obviously happening about a mile away
from here
the shoreline says absolutely the
thought that black people in america
can't get full
justice is something that we rail
against
you know it's not uncommon for our white
brothers and sisters
to get justice not only in the civil
arena
but also in the criminal arena that's
why we have
the seventh amendment as tony has on his
lapel
that's what our forefathers
conceive that justice
is for every american and not just half
justice
but whole justice and the one thing i
will simply say is this here
we have all the faith that attorney
general keith
ellison and his prosecutors are going to
zealously prosecute this case
with or without fanfare because that's
what their commitment is
and my hope is that the public sees
their uh installation their
reinstatement
of the third degree murder charge as an
example of their commitment
to give a jury every option to hold
derrick sheldon criminally reliable for
killing george floyd
now i will tell you as i've said in many
interviews
we know in black america our heart has
been broken far
too many times was something that would
be
not a hard decision if it was a white
american
that suffered what george floyd suffered
and we know the whole play but they're
going to assassinate george floyd's
character
to try to deflect our attention away
from the facts on that videotape
but it is my fervent belief that
the evidence on that videotape
can't be
minimized because george was tortured to
death
and as i said earlier
it is the most egregious and shocking
documentation of an american citizen
being tortured by
a police that most people have
ever seen in history i don't doubt
they did far worse to our ancestors back
in the
30s and 40s but that wasn't before the
advent of technology
where we saw this video where you had
the citizens
pleading with the police officer and so
we are greatly committed that
these officers should be held
accountable and we
should not say just because a black
family
gets a civil settlement that that means
they can't get criminal justice
oftentimes we have to
where we have to remember in the not so
distant past
we got no form of justice 30
35 years ago they just killed black
people
and like we said it was trivial that it
didn't matter
and so i say to all of the activists
we have to continue to protest and
demand justice for george floyd
but we do it how george floyd wanted us
to do it
peacefully right philonous i mean he
sent the tweet out in ferguson
saying we can we need to peacefully
protest
for michael brown and so his family
collectively say with the city
let's peacefully protest for george
floyd
because that's what george would want i
hope i answered your question
what question for the floyd family
rodney brandon
philonus i appreciate your courage
coming up and speaking earlier i just
want to ask you again
hey what what does this money
mean to you i know you said it can't
fulfill the love you have
for georgia and the loss you have but
what are you going to do with this money
and can you speak of
the ambiguity of that of how you get a
large sum of money but at the same time
it can't replace
someone you love
as they come forward i will say
unfortunately our legal system doesn't
have anything
else you can give to make up for the
loss
and you know i
respectfully i'm not sure white families
are asked these questions
you know it's like it's america
it's what the constitution says is
allowed
so it follows if y'all want to say
okay
some people were basically wondering
like do you all know something that we
do not know
as being right here in the city of
minneapolis and
why you all are spending so much money
barricading put involved while you're
out
and things of that nature that seems
like it's putting a world a nation of
people
at you know at ease if you will
thank you for the question i know the
the presence of some of the bolstering
around the city infrastructure uh city
hall as well as hennepin county
government center
is unsettling uh to many this was a
joint process worked through both
hennepin county as well as the city and
to be very clear
we want to encourage peaceful protesting
we
want to see people to express their
first amendment rights throughout our
city we view peaceful protesting as a
critical part of the healing process
and it's an essential part of the
democratic process we also
saw what happened on january 6 we
experienced
white supremacists come into our city in
late may and early june of 2020
and they literally used peaceful
protesters as cover to cause
chaos and havoc and we cannot have that
again
in any way shape or form thank you
two final questions yes ma'am and
brandon said make sure we get that
sister
who's been raising her hand so thank you
thank you brandon
thank you to all of you for being here
today and for answering our questions
my question goes to the family but it
also goes to
you mayor as a member of the black
community
who houses my office right on 38th in
chicago
i look out my window and i can see the
memorial
of where george took his last breath my
thought
is and my question is what is the city's
plan
and then what is the family's plan on
cup
foods
thank you for the question um i think
we're trying to be respectful of the
family here today
um i you know that's an issue i think we
can address
in another setting but we do certainly
understand
uh the community's concerns around that
business
we've had a lot of conversations uh
internally at the city about that
but to be respectful for this day and
why we're here i think
it would be good if we could follow up
uh later on that but thank you
and brandon said we will welcome your
suggestions
uh they live in houston so yes ma'am
yes ma'am do you have any thoughts on
the jury selected so far
uh uh only the
only the fact that you want a jury that
will be fair and impartial
and that will follow the law is
instructed by
the judge based on the evidence
and obviously you want a jury who will
respect
george floyd uh and not
devalue him because he was a black man
i'm a civil rights attorney and an
activist how are you doing
um one my heart goes out to
the family of george floyd you all did
not deserve
what happened george floyd didn't
deserve what happened
so we are here being respectful some of
us who are african-american who are also
activists
but we do have questions about some of
the promises that have been made by the
city
because before george floyd was killed
we went to city hall we took to the
streets we shut things down
to prevent that type of horrible
incident from happening
and we hear a lot of promises from the
people on stage with you all
crying and saying what they're gonna do
or what they wish they had done or what
they will do
but we have not seen that consistency we
haven't seen that track record
we haven't seen a real commitment to
justice and transforming the system of
policing
so we want to know that as you all are
able to
go back to your respective places we'll
still be here holding it down
we love you we want to know from city
leaders though
what tangible actions will you take next
what is the timeline and how will the
community know
that you are following through on the
promises that you have made to this
family
to these attorneys and to the world who
was watching
this press conference thank you for that
question i'm going to defer to the city
but
we we welcome you helping us hold them
accountable because
they're elected officials and black
people have to
like so many of our other citizens say
no no
you have to be accountable to us and and
i think
a lot has been said and we want to say
in the name of george floyd that
we respectfully follow up so i welcome
that question
and any assistance to work with these
leaders
nikima thank you for the question um i
think it's fair to say we all know that
there's still
a lot of work ahead and and as you know
from some of the meetings that my office
has had with the racial justice network
that we're we're organizing that work
we're trying to
roll up our sleeves and get our hands
dirty
and there's a lot to do and i'm sure
in the coming months we can continue to
speak to
what you're asking for but again i think
it's been a long day certainly for the
family
and we want to be respectful because i
know there's also travel involved
um and they also have some other uh
plans
that they'd like to do before they leave
town today so
thanks thank you all very much uh
anything else um
huh no okay thank you all very much
uh god bless you and continue to pray
for the family
and again like ben just said thank you
all so much
because uh we're here together as a team
and we're turning our purpose our pain
into purpose
thank you all so much
you